perhaps you noticed yesterday our skies
were a little hazier than usual
well a new study released today by the
american lung association says nevada's
air quality remains
unhealthy for way too many people hector
mejia is live outside with a look at
this report that gives us some pretty
low air quality grades
hector
well it says clark county is one of the
most polluted places to live and it also
says while things are improving
they're not improving fast enough and
you see all of the cars are traveling
along the i-15
transportation emissions especially from
the older vehicles are reportedly
contributing to the problem
the most while clark county passed in
terms of annual
particle pollution the american lung
association
state of the air says we are still
seeing a high number of
unhealthy spikes within a 24 hour period
the report card also listed other things
including
saying that clark county gets an ugly f
c mass last year for ozone and
short-term particle pollution
in fact it ranks 17th most polluted
county in the nation
for ozone out of the 757
counties in that study unhealthy air can
cause premature death
asthma attacks and cardiovascular damage
climate change was also listed as making
things worse
and harder to clean up so what can we do
we asked melissa ramos
manager of clean air advocacy for the
american lung association
in nevada currently in the legislature
there's a bill to close
the classic car loophole which would get
dirty
older vehicles off the road who would
not normally pass a small
smog check to make sure that we're able
to breathe healthier air
there's also an effort to bring more
zero emission transportation and
renewable energy options to the state
this year's report analyzed data from
the u.s environmental protection agency
during the years 2017
to 2019 and the report also said
nevada's pollution could be impacting
the health of
millions of people here across the state
affecting
children older adults and people of
color the most
reporting along the i-15 ndi hector
mejia
8 news now it's been a long battle to
clean our air hector for sure thank you